Вітаю вас на уроці для шостого класу.
У нас урок біології.
І я вчитель біології Ірина Юріївна.
Школа - це кайф.
Я почувала себе губкою,
котра хоче поглинути всю інформацію.
Тема нашого уроку сьогодні буде:
«Хвощі і Плауни».
І на початку,
спробуйте дати назви рослинам
на малюнках, будь ласка. Прошу.
Соняшник.
Так, будь ласка, далі.
Номер 5 – це папороть.
Абсолютно вірно.
Номер 4 – це ялинка, ні,
це хвойне дерево.
Це сосна.
Так, це сосна.
Там ще трошки схоже на
кедр, але це не він, певно.
Друге - плаун.
Абсолютно вірно.
У мене поганий зір, то другий
мені, знаєш, на що схожий?
На те, що ти любиш до м’яса
додавати, коли ми готуємо.
Розмарин. Так, розмарин.
Продовжуємо, будь ласка. Так,
номер 3 – це, а як буде «єль»?
Хвощ. А, це хвощ?
Хвощ. Теж хвощ?
Хвощ.
Так, і спробуйте вгадати номер 1?
Не бачу звідси, але схоже на листи…
Ні, це не вони?
Ми вже знаємо з вами що це – мохи.
Так це – мохи.
Перевірте, будь ласка, вашу версію.
І так, у нас є мох, є плаун, є
хвощ, є соняшник, папороть і сосна.
Спробуйте з’ясувати, а що
поєднує всі ці рослини між собою?
Що між ними спільного?
Звісно, приходить на думку,
що всі вони зеленого кольору.
Всі вони фотосинтезують.
І всі вони є вищими рослинами.
Ми з вами це вже пам’ятаємо.
Подивіться, будь ласка,
всі вищі рослини мають тіло,
почленоване на вегетативні органи.
Ці органи утворені
багатьма різними тканинами.
Давайте з вами пригадаємо. І так:
вищі рослини – це рослини
які включають в себе групи:
мохи, плауни, голонасінні,
покритонасінні, папороті і хвощі.
Покритонасінні мають
іншу назву – Квіткову.
Пригадайте, будь ласка, наш соняшник.
І правило таке:
тіло вищих рослин почленоване
на вегетативні органи
і утворене різними тканинами.
Ми з вами повторили те, що ви
вивчили на попередніх уроках.
Все живе прагне лишити нащадків.
Все живе має одну із
ознак життя – розмноження.
Тому, ми з вами зараз бачимо
на дошці цикл розмноження,
характерний для всіх
вищих спорових рослин.
Для тих, хто забув, я його нагадаю вам.
І так, статеве покоління.
Статеве покоління -
це те покоління рослин,
на якому утворюється
статеві органи, в яких власне
формуються чоловічі і
жіночі статеві клітини.
Чоловічі і жіночі статеві клітини, ми з
вами пам’ятаємо, називаються гамети.
Гамети після свого злиття утворюють
єдину клітину, яка називається зигота.
Саме з цієї клітинки починають життя
майже всі живі істоти на нашій планеті.
І так, із зиготи виростає
нестатеве покоління.
Запам’ятати дуже просто.
Нестатеве покоління
розмножується нестатево.
Ми з вами пам’ятаємо,
що спеціальні клітиночки
для нестатевого розмноження називаються
спори і утворюються
вони у спеціальних органах,
що вищі рослини вже
мають добре сформовані.
І, нарешті, із спори виростає
статеве покоління і цикл завершується.
Таким чином іде неперервне
повторення двох етапів
у циклі статевого покоління
і нестатевого покоління.
Отже, правило таке.
Статеве покоління утворює статеві органи,
в яких формуються чоловічі
та жіночі статеві клітини.
Нестатеве покоління утворює спори,
якими здійснюється нестатеве розможення.
Зверніть увагу.
Статеве покоління - статеві
органи, статеві клітини.
Нестатеве покоління - нестатеві
клітини і нестатеве розмноження.
Вони чергують одне одного.
На попередньому уроці
ви знайомилися із мохами.
Швиденько нагадую.
Перед вами, це основне, що
ви маєте пригадати з цієї теми.
І так, найпоширеніші мохи в Україні
- це зозулин льон і мох сфагнум.
На прикладі зозулиного
льону, я вам зараз нагадаю
як відбувається статеве і
нестатеве розмноження.
У мохів є одна особливість.
Подивіться, будь ласка.
У мохів пануюче покоління, тобто те
покоління, яке ми з вами чітко бачимо,
яке фотосинтезує, яке забезпечує основні
функції рослини, це покоління є статеве.
Ось, ми малюємо мох.
Я вам нагадую, що в цього
статевого покоління немає коренів,
адже мохи – це найпримітивніші
за будовою вищі рослини.
У них є спеціальні вирости,
які називаються ризоїди.
Нагадую це слово – ризоїди.
І зверху, ось тут, мох має,
принаймні – зозулин льон має,
розташовані статеві органи.
Таким чином, статеві органи, і
ми маємо – статеве покоління.
Пануючим фотосинтезуючим
є статеве покоління.
Ми пам’ятаємо, що для того, щоб
відбулося розмноження мохів,
на їх статеві органи обов’язково
має потрапити краплиночка води.
Адже ми пам’ятаємо, що
сперматозоїд - він не має крилець.
Він має лише джгутик, яким пересувається.
Тому, для того, щоб він потрапив
до яйцеклітини, йому потрібно що?
Краплинка води, по
якій він туди перепливе.
Мохи та всі вищі спорові рослини
розмножуються, в основному,
у вологих місцях для того,
щоб відбулося запліднення.
Без цього розмноження не відбудеться.
А як він потрапляє у воду?
Випадає роса, випадає
дощ – конденсується...
Тобто у всіх краплях води є?
У всіх крапляї води
немає. Є друга рослинка.
В даному випадку, нагадую, ці
рослини будуть називатися дводомні.
Тобто, будиночок для чоловічої
особини і будиночок для жіночої особини.
І, коли на них потрапляє краплинка
води (ось спільна краплинка води),
ось по цій краплинці води сперматозоїди
і потрапляють до жіночої особини.
Ще раз нагадую.
Якщо є окремо чоловіча
рослина, є окремо жіноча рослина
такі рослини називаються дводомні.
Два будиночки. Для
чоловічої і для жіночої істоти.
Якщо ж на одній рослині, нагадую,
це буде – однодомні рослини.
В одному домі і
чоловіча, і жіноча особини.
І так, відбулося запліднення.
У нас з вами зараз, на статевому
поколінні,
починає просто за рахунок
статевого покоління,
просто на ньому, починає рости
ось така штука.
Подивіться, будь ласка. Ось.
Це коробочка, це спорангій,
в якому в середині дозріває
величезна кількість спор.
В суху погоду коробочка дозріває,
розтріскується і спори розсипаються.
Ми з вами бачимо, знов-таки, цей цикл.
Мохи в суху погоду, коли не має дощику,
висипають із своєї коробочки спори і
таким чином поширюються по нашій планеті.
Таким чином ми можемо
з’ясувати, що оця частинка рослинки
– це пануюче основне
фотосинтезуюче покоління буде статеве.
А оця частинка буде яке покоління?
Нестатеве.
Нестатеве покоління.
Так, пригадуємо далі. Мох сфагнум.
Чим цей мох знаменитий?
Чим він таким нам відомий?
Дивіться, будь ласка. Ризоїди
не можуть, це не корені,
вони не можуть забезпечити
повноцінне всмоктування води.
Тому мохи не мають
повноцінних провідних тканин,
вони їх взагалі не мають, і в
них є спеціальні листочки.
Подивіться, будь ласка.
Ось листочок під мікроскопом.
Ось ми бачимо живі зелені
фотосинтезуючі клітиночки.
І мертві клітиночки, які
накопичують, вбирають в себе водичку.
Тому мохи, особливо сфагнум,
вони в місцях, де є якесь пониження,
вони накопичують величезну
кількість води і створюють болота.
Тобто, утворюють явище
заболочування ґрунтів.
В результаті того, що мох
ще й виділяє, оце –
сфагнумні мохи, або сфагнумні
болота, їх навіть називають.
Виділяє оцю водичку, спеціальну
речовину, що зупиняє розмноження бактерій.
Мох не гниє, його рештки
накопичуються, пресуються,
швидкість дуже невеличка – 1 см за
100 років, дуже-дуже повільно.
І утворюється ось такі торфові поклади.
Ось так виглядає торф.
Це суха частинка, вже
спресована багато тисяч років
для того, щоб, власне, отримати
ось таку корисну копалину.
Горючу корисну копалину.
Якщо ви спробуєте підрахувати,
спробуйте підрахувати.
Якщо за 100 років – це 1 см.
Товщина покладів торфу
може сягати до півтора метра.
Скільки часу займає
формування такого покладу?
За 100 років 1 см?
Півтора метри, скільки ж часу
займає? Спробуйте порахувати.
Помножити на 150 необхідно?
Півтора метри – це 150 см?
Так, півтора метри – 150
см помножити на 100 років.
Скільки це буде у нас?
15 тисяч?
15 тисяч років.
І так, для формування
сучасних покладів торфу
в Україні, знадобилося
майже 15 тисяч років.
Але, ми переходимо з вами далі.
І тема нашого уроку з вами «Плауни».
Уявіть собі нашу планету
680 млн. років тому.
Це кінець, так званого,
девонського періоду.
Болота, невеличкі водойми, теплий
клімат (+25 - +27 градусів за Цельсієм).
Ніяких перепадів температури.
Тільки уявіть собі, на полюсах
ростуть величезна кількість рослин.
Рослини велетенські,
рослини деревоподібні.
Ось подивіться.
Ми бачимо тут хвощі.
Бачимо які велетенські,
деревоподібні плауни.
І так, яке ж значення
плауни мають для нас зараз?
Як ми можемо поєднати
оці давні велетенські дерева,
рослини, які
існували 680 млн. років тому?
І, подивіться, будь ласка:
феєрверк, пігулки і кам’яне вугілля.
А все це між собою дійсно пов’язано.
І так, почнемо з того, що плауни
вперше почали використовувати,
до речі почали їх використовувати на
території Китаю, додаючи спори плауна.
Адже ми пам’ятаємо, що ми
розбираємо спорові рослини
і вони розмножуються спорами.
Почали додавати до спеціальних сумішей.
І, додаючи туди різні метали,
винайшли феєрверк.
Тобто, спори на половину
складаються із олії.
Нагріваючись у вогні вони різко
вибухають і маленькі частиночки того,
що додавалося в ці суміші - вони ось
утворюються такі піротехнічні засоби.
А хто перший винайшов
феєрверк? Це китайці, чи ні?
Ну, взагалі вважається,
що першими були китайці.
Так, пігулки.
На сьогодні спори використовують
як покрив для пігулок.
Для того, щоб зробити їх менш
гіркими, щоб можна було їх проковтнути.
Крім того, ці ж спори використовуються
для найкращих, для найдорожчих,
для найтендітніших діточок –
це присипка для маленьких дітей.
В її теж додають спори, бо вони
майже наполовину складаються із олії.
І кам’яне вугілля.
Подивіться, будь ласка. Ось такі
поклади, вони сприяли тому, що:
дерева падали, не
перегнивали, накопичувалося,
накопичувалося, пресувалося, заносилося
мулом, заносилося піском, і, врешті-решт,
утворилися сучасні
поклади кам’яного вугілля.
Якими ми з вами сьогодні і користуємося.
Тепер давайте познайомимося із плаунами,
які є на території України.
Подивіться, будь ласка.
Плауни баранець має такі, як на хутро,
на хутро баранця, схожі,
кругленькі закручення.
Це рослина, яка у нас поширена,
в основному, у хвойних лісах.
Знов таки – вологі ліси, так?
І плаун булавоподібний, подивіться,
будь ласка, у нього спороносні колоски –
ті місця де дозрівають спори, тут
вже не коробочки, як було у мохів.
Не коробочки, як було у
мохів, а спороносні колоски.
Оці спороносні колоски, вони, якраз таки,
і утворюють ось такі
органи для утворення спор.
Але тут є один маленький
момент, зверніть, будь ласка, увагу.
Якщо у мохів пануючим
поколінням було статеве,
тобто фотосинтезуюче –
основне, яке забезпечує
живлення і розвиток
повноцінної рослини, то у плаунів
пануючим поколінням
буде – нестатеве покоління.
Нестатеве – це їх суттєва відмінність.
Спори у них дозрівають на поверхні цього
нестатевого покоління і утворюють
ось такі колосочки, які
ми називаємо стробіли,
або просто можна казати – колосочки.
Цикл розвитку плаунів.
Знов знайомий вам цикл. Ми
його вже сьогодні пригадували.
І так, спори у нас є пануюче
покоління – це нестатеве покоління.
Спори утворюються у спорангіях
(органи де утворюються спори).
Спора – спорангій, спору утворюю.
Із спори виростає статеве
покоління, маленька-маленька
ниточка, маленька-маленька
зелененька ниточка.
У плавунів, ця зелененька ниточка нагадує
водорість, ззовні нагадує водорість.
Може розвиватися до 10 років,
аж поки на ній не утворяться
органи для статевого розмноження,
не утворяться гамети.
Потім - не утвориться зигота, і не
виросте нове, нестатеве покоління.
А які розміри цієї рослини?
Розмір цієї рослини, якщо, власне,
плаун баранець має розмір,
приблизно, як моя долоня.
Ага, і він такий маленький?
Скільки років він може рости?
Це трав’янисті, вічнозелені,
багаторічні рослини.
Ще одна особливість –
стебло стелиться по ґрунту.
І стебло вилчасто галузиться,
від слова «вилочка».
Означає, що воно буде
ділитися ось таким чином.
Це характерна вилочка,
ось, буде ділитися на два.
І ще, воно буде стелитися по землі.
Ось так, приблизно, це буде виглядати.
І зверху спороносні колосочки.
Ось так виглядають плауни.
Це якась рослина завойовник. Так?
Ні, це рослина не завойовник,
це наша рідна рослина.
Тож ми маємо запам’ятати.
Плаун фотосинтезує нестатеве
покоління, тому це покоління пануюче.
Спорангії зібрані у колоски.
Це частина нестатевого покоління.
Додаткові корені, які ростуть
від стебла, що стелиться по ґрунту.
Лускоподібні листки.
Дрібні-дрібні лускоподібні листочки.
І, звісно, повзуче стебло,
яке вилчасто галузиться.
Наступним розділом нашого уроку
ми з вами знайомимося із хвощами.
Всі ви рано на весні,
мабуть, бачили, що з ґрунту
з’являються ось такі
незрозумілі буруваті вирости.
Буруваті пагони.
Розказую вам секрет – це
весняний пагін хвоща польового.
Основне призначення цього пагону –
розсипати спори, які в ньому дозрівають.
Він слугує виключно для
нестатевого розмноження.
Подивіться будь ласка.
Кореневище, яке є видозміненим
пагоном і зберігається в ґрунті.
Воно зимує і не просто
зберігається, воно має
ось такі бульбочки, які
накопичують поживні речовини.
Подивіться. Красивий, зелений,
вже звичний нам з вами літній пагін,
все літо фотосинтезує, накопичуючи
крохмаль в ось цих бульбочках.
Коли взимку відмирає літній пагін,
тобто, в кінці літа – восени відмирає
літній пагін,
то рослина зимує.
І навесні не фотосинтезуючи, а
за рахунок запасу ось цих бульбочок
розвивається весняний пагін,
який і починає розкидати спори.
Це як у ведмедів.
Чому він має розкидати спори?
Подивіться, будь ласка, на фотографію.
Ми бачимо оці пагони і
бачимо, що рослини інші,
що ростуть поряд, тільки-тільки
починають проростати.
Яке це має значення?
Спори розкидати треба якомога далі.
Якщо б це було зроблено
пізніше, то високо виросла
трава і спори просто так
далеко не розлетілися б.
А для того, щоб спори розлетілися, у
кожної спори є спеціальні чотири пружинки.
Вони називаються елетери.
Ці спори скручені. Ці пружинки скручені.
Як тільки стає суха погода,
ці спори починають підсихати.
І, як пружина, із силою розкриваються
і відстрілюють на кілька сантиметрів.
Іноді навіть на кілька десятків
сантиметрів від рослини,
від спороносного пагона
- таким чином хвощ поширюється,
має ось такі, спеціальні пружинки.
Що стосується його особливості будови.
Фотосинтезує пагін, оце все – пагони.
Листочки в нього у вигляді
ось таких, невеличких лусочок.
Листки не фотосинтезують.
Рослина фотосинтезує
повноцінними пагонами.
Знов таки, так само як і у
плаунів, це є нестатеве покоління.
Тобто, пануючим буде
теж нестатеве покоління.
Ви знаєте, я тепер
по-іншому буду ходити по лісу.
Буду шукати плауни, буду шукати хвощі.
Зверніть, будь ласка, увагу.
Хвощ польовий, який зустрічається
в Україні як злісний бур’ян,
його всі намагаються на полі позбутися
– є індикатором кислих ґрунтів.
Крім того, він накопичує в собі
кремній, який можна використовувати,
якщо у вас немає поряд якоїсь
ганчірки, щоб помити посуд.
Його можна використовувати
для миття посуду.
Особливо добре його використовують
в походах, для миття казанків.
Найкраще пристосування,
спробуйте при нагоді.
Цикл розвитку хвощів.
В цьому циклі ми з вами бачимо
вже більше малюнків і менше позначок.
Давайте спробуємо самі їх відновити.
Статеве покоління.
Маленький заросток,
якого практично не видно.
Він дуже маленький, його життя нетривале,
але на ньому утворюються статеві органи.
В статевих органах формуються гамети.
Після запліднення утворюється
клітина, що називається зигота.
Із зиготи виростає яке покоління?
Статеве чи нестатеве? Нестатеве
Нестатеве, абсолютно
вірно, це правильна відповідь.
Нестатеве покоління –
оце є спороносний пагін.
Тому в спороносному пагоні,
ось тут, зверху, формується …
Спора.
Спори, абсолютно вірно.
Ми бачимо спори із елетерами.
Пригадайте, ми це знаємо,
навіщо потрібні пружинки?
Щоб якнайдалі розлетітися в різні боки.
І, нарешті, з цих спор виростає
статеве покоління і цикл завершується.
І так, ми маємо запам’ятати.
Фотосинтезує стебло літнього пагона.
Спорангії збираються
у, так звані, колоски.
Пригадайте, весняний пагін.
Є додаткові корені,
які ростуть від стебла.
Є лускоподібні листки,
які не фотосинтезують.
Кореневище із бульбочками, які
накопичують поживні речовини на зиму.
І так, перевіряємо здобуті знання.
Перше питання.
Назвіть корисну копалину, яка утворилась
здебільшого за рахунок
відмерлих решток моху.
Торф чи що? І так, вірна відповідь?
В. Торф.
Далі…
Що таке заросток?
Питання трошки складніше.
Адже ми з вами вперше
сьогодні почули цей термін.
Так, давай поміркуємо.
Заросток, це те, що з’являється першим,
тобто це має бути або частина
пагона? Я так думаю.
Це нестатеве покоління. Варіант Б.
Так, повертаємось до нашого малюнку.
Хто ж такий заросток?
І правильна відповідь, це – Г.
Особина статевого покоління.
І третє питання.
Даю підказку. Ці корені ростуть
від пагона. І так, ваша відповідь?
Отже, точно, додаткові. Абсолютно
вірно. Це додаткові корені.
Наш урок закінчено, дзвоник пролунав.
На все добре, до зустрічі.
Дякуємо.
Дякуємо, і по-перше, я хотів сказати Вам,
спасибі за можливість
з’явитися знову у школі.
Це були дуже цікаві часи.
Аж захотілося до їдальні
сходити та взяти піцу шкільну.
Ну ти як завжди.
Ще може ще чогось? Компотика…
В шкільні роки, ти
підходиш до цього несвідомо.
До тієї цікавої інформації,
яку тобі розповідають.
Щось в одне вухо
влетіло, в інше – вилетіло…
Поки ти вчишся, ти не дуже любиш школу,
але коли виростеш –
будеш згадувати ці часи,
як одні з найвеселіших
та найкращих років.
Я чоловіку говорила: «Так, милий, бачиш,
якщо ми з тобою підемо в похід
і треба буде помити
казанок, то ми тепер знаємо,
якою саме рослиною ми можемо це зробити».
Школа – це кайф.
Тому що м'яз... Чому?
Тому що повітря потрапляє у легені...
Котику, допоможи мені.
Правильно,ні?
У павука вісім ніг.
Тому що хтось забув його
поставити у холодильник?
Але із скислого молока можна
зробити чудовий домашній сир.
Звичайно, ви ж згадайте...
Був вірш "Папороть
цвіте". Звичайно цвіте.
А, його шукали... це міф. Ага.
Камяне вугілля утворюється
дуже багато років,
Від хвощів, плющів та ще інших рослин.
Точно сказати не можу.